challenges for the next 10 years in
Latin America would be the integration
of the region should finish the reason
that Spanish countries face the Pacific
and Brazil faces the Atlantic should
integrate both sides of Latin America so
that it can be seen and interact as a
whole second challenge but not least
important than the first month is the
rise of new leadership in the region you
should have engagement you should have
strategic vision we should have
commitment the welfare of the people
from Latin America coming from the top
of our leaders so we should have new
people new mindsets new vision to the
leadership what